chemi the alchemical transformation well
of course there is a
a strong theory or strong practical
aspect of it but it is
a myth now of course some of you may
have been
indoctrinated by newspapers and other
horrible
things saying that a myth is is a lie
a myth is something that isn't true
a myth is truer than physical
truth a myth is even more true than
intellectual truth and maybe with our
motto that
hpv and colonel you know they took it i
believe from the
michael will either beat me up
afterwards or agree with me
i think they took it from the maharaja
of benares
or satya nasty para dharma my sanskrit
is bad
but you see that there is no dharma
higher
than truth now what is that truth
is it a is it a teaching is it a
doctrine
is it a set of commandments of rules
no what is it
it is the authenticity
of being it is the
the reality of the truth beyond
earthly truth and one of the main
manifestations is that
little truth of course that resides
within us
but that truth has been
expressed throughout the ages in
india by the puranas
in tibet by uh various myths
in the western initially by the greeks
and so forth in
mythic form and we are and i see
every manifestation of the esoteric
tradition has
its myth and that means again it's it's
not
not an intellectual thing but it's
something that is trying to tell you
uh something ineffable that cannot be
told really effectively in any other
way we mentioned freemasonry well
there is the myth of hiram and various
other things everywhere there is a myth
the christian religion there is the myth
of jesus christ
primarily in others and these are not
falsehoods
but they are a tale
told about mysterious things
which you cannot really effectively
convey
in any other way hpv knew this
they're all